my wife and I went and saw the new
Dungeons and Dragons movie and the first
thing that happens is a giant bad guy
comes in he's a monster he's huge comes
up to a woman the woman just beats the
crap out of him and I thought yeah
you've already lost me women no longer
know who they're supposed to be and they
get insulted if you say to them well you
may be many things but the one thing
you're not is a man you know and so you
have to understand what you are as a
woman and that that has been outlawed as
a as an idea one of the things you said
to me because we met here last year
and I still remember this we were
talking about screenwriting and and
writing in general and you said
every great Story begins with a boy and
a girl
and once I got past the transphobia and
the homophobia of that statement
it really made me think because that is
so fundamentally true
and yeah I I think we've become quite
uncomfortable with telling a story as
basic as that or a story that's is based
on such a simple thing well women no
longer exist as characters in the movies
you cannot go to the movies uh and see a
woman who is anything like a woman that
you would actually meet unless you date
uh wrestlers you know what I mean you
know
probably I mean if when you talk about
you know before their cameras are
rolling we're talking about all the
controversial things we say and how
people get angry yeah maybe the thing
that made people angrier than anything
else I've ever said on the air was I I
saw a show The Witcher in which the
woman was fighting a duel
and I said
women can't fight duels with men that's
not the way that works I mean if it's
the Middle Ages and you're in an actual
battle not on a fencing field
those guys were like you know it's not
like you'd be fighting me you'd be
fighting a guy this gigantic guy and
he'd come and just wipe you off the face
of the Earth if you have a character and
a fantasy who's a woman she should have
some magical power because women do have
that but but you can't keep putting
women in who fight because that doesn't
happen in real life and and when my
daughter was growing up there would be a
scene and a woman would punch a guy and
the guy would roll ass over teeth and I
would say to her you know if you punch a
guy the first thing that happens is your
pan breaks and the second thing that
happens is he beats the living crap out
of you you know and so don't don't ever
think that that's the real thing so
feminism destroyed
the character of the woman and yet
that's what stories are about they're
about whether a woman can be
um womanly enough and whether a man can
be manly enough to keep life going to
keep the planet you know the human race
uh continuing
um and and in telling that story you
were telling an essential uh what's
called a psychomochy the the inner
battle that we all fight to bring
together the pieces of ourselves because
we all have female and male elements and
we when you put those together uh you
are getting something like the image of
God you know in which we are made and so
that story is is the story and once you
lose that story you're not telling any
story at all and it really is
interesting I mean I went just the other
day my wife and I went and saw the new
Dungeons and Dragons movie and the first
thing that happens is a giant bad guy
comes in tip is a classic scene because
this is the scene where Brad Pitt is
reading the script and says oh yeah I
want to play that part bad guy comes in
he's a monster he's huge comes up to a
woman the woman just beats the crap out
of him and I thought yeah you've already
lost me you know the rest and and in
fact the film is entertaining it's
beautiful but it's dead inside it has no
inside because that character that
female character women no longer know
who they're supposed to be and they get
insulted if you say to them well you may
be many things but the one thing you're
not is a man you know and so you have to
understand what you are as a woman and
that that has been outlawed as a as an
idea and signify something in the
culture to me that that very basic it's
the core it's like a house without a
foundation
well you know I I wrote this book The
the truth and beauty and I have a
chapter on Frankenstein by Mary Shelley
and I point out that when people read
Frankenstein it really starts the
science fiction genre she basically
invents the modern uh science fiction
drawing when people read that they
always say well Frankenstein wanted to
be God he wanted to create life and Mary
Shelley herself said this and I thought
no men do create life men and women do
create life he wants to replace not God
he wants to replace the mother he wants
to create a life without a woman and and
that is to a large degree with science
fiction is about and to a large and even
larger and worst degree with science is
about it has been a long uh attempt to
eliminate the fertility
and the difference of women because men
are afraid of that power and that's what
Mary Shelley I thought first saw that
you know if you think of think of a
movie like The Terminator you know the
machines take over and they and the
people rebel so how do they stop the
Rebellion they go back in time to kill
the hero's mother
and if you watch that first brilliant
film
the woman they want to kill
she has nothing special about her except
she she's a girl that's her superpower
you know and they know they've got to
kill her because that's the Machine
World depends on women being taken away
this is you know just right this moment
people were yelling at me on Twitter
because I said we should uh boycott
Anheuser-Busch for putting a boy
pretending to be a girl on one of their
beer cans they said oh this is such a
small thing why are you getting so upset
this is everything this is everything
the role of women in a society who after
all create humankind
um is is everything and that's why
societies that have Freer women who
liberate women who have respect for
women that's why they Thrive and
societies that don't get stuck in a kind
of medieval uh half-life
and it's important because soon there'll
be machines that give birth
and then we'll turn to women and say and
what do you what's special about you I
can run faster than you I'm stronger
than you are I can do math better than
you can do it what is it you do again
and they'll have lost their vocation
it's a dangerous dangerous moment and
because our Humanity depends on them
it's such a profound point and that's
that is really what we're seeing and
we're seeing it right the way through
our culture
when are we going to wake up from this
Andrew well hopefully you know we're not
going to wake up until women get angry
and and this is the thing you know uh my
friend and colleague at the daily wire
Candace Owens was just saying when they
did it to Budweiser beer
suddenly Budweiser beer took an economic
hit and she said why because Men drink
Budweiser beer and they get angry but
women not real men not right no of
course not and certainly not men with
any taste and beer or anything but but
she was just saying that men don't take
this stuff quite as much as women do
women have been convinced
my problem with feminism is always the
same thing it was always it was not that
women shouldn't have choices it was that
their values are men's values they say
oh you're just a homemaker
I think really just a homemaker I mean
is I mean isn't the home the basic
building block of the State uh you know
just you're just raising children you're
just creating new people that has been
the feminist uh archetype from the very
beginning uh Simone de beauvois said
women should not be allowed to stay home
and raise their kids because too many
women will choose to do that and they
have been convincing women uh that this
is a minor thing this is being thrown
out of the society So when you say how
long will this last the answer is until
you start to have women saying wait a
minute wait a minute we've been duped
we've been duped out of ourselves and
you're starting to see it now I mean we
were talking about Mary Harrington who's
just This brilliant uh you know Oxford
educated thinker and she you know had a
baby she was totally in with the left
had a baby and she thought no I actually
kind of like this I actually kind of
want to do this and when more thinking
women have that kind of Courage
then you've got you'll have ideas
trickling down that will counter
feminism because feminism has just been
a mistake it has made everybody
miserable
you wonder why yeah Twitter
foreign